and this one for my bike baby that
it's the little things that matter when
you have nothing
forced to make a new life for his
children from donations
ali shows me the last picture of him and
his sons in kabul he's my 10 years old
and the oldest escaping the taliban
leaving all they knew
in afghanistan he worked with the
british council so feared for his life
we're protecting his identity and aren't
using his real name definitely if you
were there
so we would be assassinated
because we were accused and we were
blamed for the
as a british spy
i could not believe that how to live
but we had to do that in order to save
our life
this is my baby daughter
this was taken in the hotel where they
quarantined when they arrived in the uk
they now have a temporary home in the
west midlands
but many are still waiting stuck in
hotels with nowhere to go we receive
phone calls and
contacts by the these people uh they
wanted to know when they will be housed
some of them still
in hotels so there's a lot lots of
uncertainty uh with the housing issues
and where they will be going next you
have children obviously they need to
start schooling and with the rest of the
support they need coventry is one city
that is welcoming refugees pledging to
house 150 people arriving from
afghanistan but many councils are still
refusing to take anyone we will seek
judicial review
for the government to actually ensure
that the dispersal program and the
dispersal process is fairer than it
currently is and it's around
communication
66 people from afghanistan have arrived
in coventry
and it's a home office program home
office abilited them but we didn't know
about it
grateful for any help
[Music]
these people just need somewhere to call
home but now they're in the uk
it's not clear where they're all going
to live becky johnson sky news in the
west midlands